we've been talking about the Niners with
Jimmy Garoppolo Doug Gottlieb from Fox
Sports Radio driving into work and
wanted to win hi Doug
hey guys Dan sorry yeah I hope I didn't
run the run the ship off course Friday
when I got there so employee I hope you
had a Happy Thanksgiving
thank you for doing that I appreciate
that Doug very very nice of you I was
just like look I kind of agree with
seating here I mean like what what are
we missing it's the trend in sports the
Sixers tanked it's working right they
have two burgeoning superstars on the
roster and look every every pic does not
hit there's a like a hit rate right
maybe it's maybe it's 50/50 and then you
look at the Astros same thing they tank
for years they were so bad
a star so bad in 2013 they got a blue
tarski a 0.0 local rating on on their
local broadcast which is which is
unheard of in baseball but it worked
because you get enough picks you move
them around
look at the young pieces they have under
Club control and they win a World Series
and they're going to be competitive for
years to come they do sit down Dallas
Keuchel I mean they you're they're not
playing Judy Garoppolo it's a different
sport I mean like you think Ben Simmons
couldn't play at all last year you know
I mean you think you know they and they
keep they got they got kids kid gloves
on Joel embiid
I mean look in in this particular sport
you're running a risk of Jimmy Garoppolo
getting hurt and you're your best you
have no chance of success ultimate
success this year and you put yourself
in strong position to trade those picks
do every time every every every loss it
creates a greater possibility of getting
what the second the first or second
overall yeah and we've seen how valuable
that is would you join the year of the
quarter Doug would you give Jimmy
Garoppolo a hundred million dollars no
but you know what look I don't I'm not
the reason they got John Lynch and the
reason they got Kyle Shanahan is because
they believe those two can evaluate the
one position on the field that is the
hardest to evaluate and now they have
him in their building right so they
obviously think he's the guy so what I
probably not but would I go take the
words when I take the word of John Lynch
and Kyle Shanahan yes I would so if they
say give him a hundred million because
they've been around the block and I
probably give him a hundred million but
but what happens if you give him that
kind of contract then next year that the
Niners are let's say three and thirty
three and ten do you then sit him out
because the games don't mean anything
and no reason to put him in there
because you might get hurt like it at
what point do you say really but
potentially I mean chin chin to chin the
Giants be doing that right I mean
honestly the Giants would agree the way
you like Manning for the Jaguars
yeah but like you're not gonna sit a lie
now because Eli is probably not your
quarterback next year so who cares if he
gets injured so wait you got to find out
what you got in Davis Webb what I
haven't Jimmy Garoppolo obviously they
do though
that's the disappoint like Kyle Shanahan
does you have tape on him you've seen
him in your practices now you've seen a
little bit your games John Lynch has
obviously seen him when he evaluated
when you've worked for Fox Sports like I
look I agree with you I don't know it's
it's a mysterious thing if he's really
that good but it's pretty obvious that
Kyle Shannon thinks he's that good
that's why trade for him knowing is
gonna have to pay for him yeah but then
you're gonna set up a scenario where
it's a meaningless game next season and
then the season after that it's a
meaningless game and then all of a
sudden Jimmy Garoppolo doesn't play but
but you win this thing based like the
Chip Kelly had no chance last year cuz
they had no talent right they strip this
thing down they had no talent and they
did pretty well it they did really well
in their first draft and so like this is
the philosophy right they were clearly
tanking when you put it when you say hey
we're signing Brian Hoyer to be our guy
you're like all right you're playing for
next year yeah and they probably
evaluated Josh Rosen who looks the part
but everybody thinks is not a leader
he's got something missing in his in his
in his make up that they evaluated
Arnold and they're like dude Arnold's
got all the leadership but man there's a
lot of stuff to work through
they evaluate all the other college
quarterbacks you know what Jimmy
Garoppolo he's been trained by the best
played with the best he's played a
little bit we think he fits into what we
want to do I mean I'm sure Kyle Shanahan
probably has some arrogance to which he
thinks I developed Kirk Cousins into
being a franchise caliber quarterback
and it would cost way too much be way
too hard to sign him as a free agent
instead of a second round pick and
whenever you have to pay for for Jimmy
Garoppolo I agree and it's gonna work
we're in agreement on getting Garoppolo
I thought it was great that they traded
for him absolutely
I'm sure I'm shocked the Browns didn't
go and pay more for him yes I understand
all of it I'd like to see him play the
brown yeah but I don't want to sit here
and go boy you know what this is a
meaningless game Jimmy you're not gonna
play today like you know that's just
that's not the paid you start him
against the Bears this weekend
probably not there's no reward for being
okay like that's the problem with the
system right is there's just no reward
so much better off being terrible and
getting a better pic and trading that
pic for more pain I understand the
numbers game and getting more talent I
understand that but at some point I have
to see him play him if I'm gonna pony up
100 million dollars all right Doug thank
you for calling it it's always great to
talk to you
that's a dougie fresh Fox Sports Radio
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]